um I I think there's really just one
more thing definitely to share with you
Brad especially since you said all of
those nice happy holidays messages to
everyone um I have something for you
from a lot of different people as well
so I'm glad I went first yeah you did
yeah you hit I think almost most of the
people in this so okay
good hi I'm am Cassie Star Girl cast on
Discord I just wanted to say happy
holidays to everybody and I hope you
have a fun safe fantastic holiday happy
holidays you filthy animals from Sidra
all I can hope for for 2024 is the MGM
and Amazon come down our chimney with
the best present of all brand new
Stargate happy holidays my name is Mara
and my favorite fandom memory from 2023
would have to be either the companion's
first ever trivia night or their first
ever Social Hour Merry Christmas
everyone my name's Gemma and in 2024 for
I'm looking forward to more Stargate
events that bring the fandom together in
a fun and positive way hello everyone
David Reed for dial the gate wishing you
a very happy holiday season and a
healthy and prosperous 2024 see you in
the new
year hi everyone I'm Sophie one of my
expectation for next year is meeting you
in person happy holidays take care bye
happy holidays everyone I'm Gabriela I
found starting in 2012 when I was eight
it was sg1 season 1 episode 4 and I'm
addicted ever soon hi Merry Christmas
I'm
Ashley and I found Stargate years ago
but it's a show that you can keep coming
back to that's why I love it happy
holidays everyone from three fresh
shorts wishing everyone a safe and
healing New Year let's close the iris on
2023 three in style hello I'm Peter so
on Discord my favorite fandom memory
from this year is crossplaying for the
first time as Rodney McKay in his nice
leather jacket and doing that at MCM
London 2023 where there's also the Star
Trek strange new worlds there so M
transported into Star Trek hello
everybody happy happy Holidays happy
Christmas happy Hanukkah happy K Quanza
and all the happy rolled into one I just
wanted to say uh I hope everybody's
having an amazing festive season here's
to a rocking rolicking 2024 let's make
it a good one and in the words of hath I
say Brad right baby slip a starget under
the tree for
me I've been an off a good girl Brad
right baby and hurry to my tell
tonight oh Merry marry everyone lots of
love that was great that was wonderful
she's a really good singer oh yeah she's
been doing a whole show recently I think
in London so yeah pretty amazing that's
fun that's really fun well that was
lovely that was really
[Music]
lovely